hey this is presh talwalkar
thanks to mustoba ali in bangladesh for
sending me this problem
two brothers a and b
have the exact same walking speed and
the exact same running speed
one day they started the same trip to
the same place
brother a
walked for half of the distance and ran
the rest
while brother b
walked for half of the time and ran for
the other half of time
which brother reached the end of the
trip first
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so there are many ways to solve this
problem and i'm going to present three
different methods
first i'll explain the answer using
logical reasoning then i'll go over a
method of using concrete numbers and
finally i'll give a formal algebraic
proof
so let's get started with logical
reasoning
brother a runs for half of the distance
so brother a must be running for less
than half of the time
this is because brother a also walks
half the distance and walking the same
distance takes more time than running
since brother b runs half the time
brother b is running for more time and
walking for less time so brother b will
be faster and complete the journey first
amazing we solve this without doing any
actual numerical calculation
but if that wasn't convincing to you you
could use concrete numbers and use your
poetic license to fill in distances and
speeds that were not specified in the
problem
so let's suppose brother a walks 500
miles and then runs 500 more just to be
the man to go 1000 miles to fall down at
your door
imagine both brothers walk at a rate of
5 miles per hour and run at a rate of 10
miles per hour
how long will brother a take
we take half the distance of 500 and
divide it by the walking speed of 5 then
we take the other half of 500 and divide
it by the running speed of 10 to get a
total of 150 hours
now brother b runs two times as fast so
he must run two times the distance to
have an equal running time and walking
time
so we can then calculate he must run for
one thousand times two-thirds miles and
he must walk for one thousand times one
third miles
we can then calculate brother b's total
time for the trip
this will be the walking distance of one
thousand over three divided by the
walking speed of five
plus the running distance of one
thousand times two
divided by the running speed of ten
this results in a total time of 133 and
one-third hours
so this is less time than brother a so
brother b completes the trip
first
now let's just go over a formal proof
suppose the total distance is d units
the walking speed is w units per hour
and the running speed is r units per
hour and suppose r is greater than w
the total time that brother a takes will
be half the distance divided by the
walking speed plus half the distance
divided by the running speed
we make a common denominator and this
simplifies to be the distance d times
the quantity r plus w all over the
quantity to rw
now to calculate the average speed of
brother a we take the total distance and
divide it by the total time
this simplifies to be the quantity 2rw
divided by the quantity r plus w
this is the harmonic mean of the two
numbers r and w
now brother b's calculation for average
speed is much easier his speed is a
simple arithmetic average because he's
running for half the time and walking
for half the time
so his average speed is the quantity r
plus w all over two
so which brother is faster
brother a has an average speed equal to
the harmonic mean of r and w while
brother b has an average speed equal to
the arithmetic mean of r and w
for two distinct positive numbers the
arithmetic mean is always larger this is
a well-known property and i've linked to
a proof of that in the video description
therefore brother b has a larger or
faster average speed so he will finish
the trip first
thanks for watching this video
i post math videos that you can watch
for free and i've so far stayed free
with no sponsors for very important
reasons
if you'd like to support the channel
here's how you can help
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos
also watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos so that more people can
discover this channel
you can email me a math topic or puzzle
suggestion at presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you like this video you can also
check out my books which are linked in
the video description and if you so
choose you can financially support this
channel on patreon
thanks for watching and thank you for
supporting this channel